Uncle Tim's it's all good and that's no
bull
it's frosty out this morning
25.
this morning
cannot feed the
guilts they're up there in the forest
they'll come running here in a second
[Music]
okay
here they come
on hey big big
ready for breakfast
some of you might wonder how pigs keep
warm
when it's cold outside if they're not
in some sort of a shelter
they do that by building themselves
nests you can see
well I'm not sure how well it shows up
on the video but
there's where one of the pigs spent the
night and the ground is literally
steaming
because it's so warm compared to
outside
so they dig themselves in
used a bunch of old grass and
debris from the trees there
and it's just steaming step stayed warm
over here I have straw you can see some
here there I just have straw spread
around the
Forest here in different areas for them
and they'll get themselves all nice and
cozy and that helps keep them warm it
insulates them from the
from the ground but yeah
they're able to keep warm
as long as they have
a proper amount of feed
to feed their
system they can keep themselves warm
foreign
[Music]